you just ordered a Tesla congratulations
what you'll quickly find out is no news
is good news at least that's what Tesla
tells you however if you like most
people you're going to end up on YouTube
trolling through hundreds of videos to
find all the information I know because
this was exactly me just a few months
ago the other week we took delivery of
our brand new Tesla Model Y and it is an
incredible car something that is
definitely worth purchasing and pursuing
however the months leading up to it were
painstakingly hard we were constantly
looking at all sorts of different
information trying to figure out what
was going on so that's why I decided to
make this video today What to Expect
When You're Expecting if you stick
around to the end of the video I'll
share with you exactly how I managed to
track my Tesla as it was being shipped
into the country a hundred percent for
free this gave me a very good indication
of how it was progressing what the
delivery updates were and where my car
was but let's dive in you've just
pressed that order button you've paid
your 350 deposit whatever it may be for
your vehicle and you've gotten the
little dancing Hedgehog it's probably
one of the weirdest car buying
experiences you've ever had in your life
what you're going to notice is you're
automatically going to be asked to start
creating your Tesla account this Tesla
account is going to be the be all
end-all throughout this whole experience
this is where you're going to be
checking for updates and this is where
you're going to get most of your
information from one thing that you want
to pay close attention to is your RN
number this is your order number for the
vehicle and it will be your primary
reference if you ever need a ring Tesla
and actually ask for some information
shortly after your purchase you're going
to get a text message from Tesla it's
going to congratulate and welcome you to
the Tesla family this text message is
going to keep coming throughout the
entire process as more and more updates
happen about your vehicle so you don't
actually need to keep checking your
Tesla account because you're either
going to get a text message or an email
or both with an update of what's going
on they will then redirect you to this
Tesla account so make sure you set up
your account go through all the details
fill in the background information and
make make sure your Tesla account is 100
set up ready to go if you're like me and
in most cases you're going to order your
Tesla and nothing's going to happen for
a little while for example we ordered
the Tesla Model y day one in Australia
we ordered it in the afternoon so we're
unfortunately pushed back to the second
shipment that means we waited five
months for our vehicle I know this isn't
a very long time especially some people
waiting years however you are most
likely going to be waiting a little
while it isn't going to be an instant
delivery the time period between
notifications is most likely going to be
quite long but what you can do is
actually try and figure out your vehicle
VIN number well and truly before you
have any paperwork so there is a free
VIN application that you can download
and install into Google Chrome it's
simply called Tesla Vin finder I'll link
it down below to make it easy for you
guys absolutely no affiliation I just
used it to try and figure out what my
VIN was extremely early if you don't
want to download and install the VIN
finder you can search through the source
code of the actual account page to
figure out if your VIN is available on
not this is just a bit more of a tedious
task about two months before we took
delivery of our brand new model y we got
a text message from Tesla saying your
documentation for registration is now
ready what you have to do is jump online
onto your account fill out this
paperwork and then email it through
Tesla they don't tell you about this
nobody tells you where to send it you
actually have to do a little bit of
research to figure out where it needs to
go so out of pure excitement I managed
to fill out all these paperwork
immediately send it back to Tesla and
again no news is supposedly good news
unfortunately for me I ended up having
to resend this email about three or four
times and even still there was a mad
rush the day before we took our delivery
to actually get this paperwork finished
so I do strongly recommend that whenever
you send these paperwork across the
Tesla give them a quick call or a quick
follow-up email just to make sure that
they have received this documentation I
know they don't want you to contact them
I know they want to be left alone but
unfortunately in my situation it was
almost delayed delivery just because
they had so many emails come through and
they completely mislined if you've
already downloaded the Tesla app when
you actually purchased your vehicle
you're going to see the estimated
delivery date or the EDD change at this
point in time as well for me personally
it jumped to a two-week window at the
very start of November some people have
told me that their edds haven't actually
changed until the vehicle has arrived in
the country so sometimes your very large
window of three months we'll drop down
to two weeks quite early other times
you're going to have to wait a little
bit longer don't get too excited though
that first two week estimated delivery
date is just basically a lie most of the
time you're not going to get it in that
first two week block that two weeks is
going to continuously jump around so
don't plan things around that two-week
delivery time actually wait until you
have something locked in before you
start finalizing bits and pieces now
about six weeks before we took delivery
we got another text message from Tesla
saying your final invoice is ready we
mistakenly actually took this as a great
sign that our model y was in the country
and unfortunately that wasn't the case
but we did end up paying the invoice off
at that point in time what you need to
know is you do not have to pay for this
model y or any of the Teslas until 48
hours before delivery usually I'd
recommend three to four days before that
just so you can make sure that all the
bank transfers go through properly
especially if you're going through
Finance if you do want to pay an
installments and pay this vehicle off
whilst you're waiting you can actually
contribute to this bank account that
they provide you with and slowly start
paying off in installments once the
final invoice is activated you will just
get a numerous amount of emails and text
messages afterwards saying your final
balance has been updated that means
they've received your money and you can
just keep topping it off as you go along
they will keep track of it so it is okay
if you do wish to actually pay off
installments and not just do one big
lump sum if you didn't install that then
find a back in the day then you can also
find your VIN right now on this final
invoice this bin is going to allow you
to figure out where your vehicle is how
it's tracking and where it's being
shipped to about seven days after you
receive your final invoice is available
message you're going to get another one
from Tesla now Tesla's going to give you
an update saying that your model y has
been assigned to your order this is
again great news it means that delivery
date is inching closer now at this point
in time once you have your VIN number
and once you have your vehicle assigned
to you you can actually go ahead and
start tracking it there are two ways to
do this you can do this 100 free or you
can actually go through a paid service I
think the paid service is probably very
good and probably worth the money
considering how much time I dedicated to
trying to track down my vehicle so if
you want to pay the money I believe the
account is better Prime you can find it
through Google it's quite easy to find
and utilize their service instead what I
managed to figure out is that my vehicle
was on a row row ship all Teslas go on
row row ships and through these railroad
ships you can then determine which
carrier it is and where they're actually
being shipped from in Australia there
are only two row row carriers that come
in at the moment it's actually only one
taking up predominantly most of the
delivery that company is mole Ace
m-o-l-a-c-e once you have your VIN
number you can jump onto the mole Ace
website go to the search function change
over to a VIN number paste in your
actual VIN number and it will tell you
which vessel your car is on once you've
figured out what vessel it's on then you
can simply type in that vessel name into
Google directly and jump onto vessel
finder in my instance for example it was
on a ship called Victorious Ace that
means I went on Google typed in
Victorious Ace and it quickly told me
exactly where that ship was I knew when
it was going to be arriving at the Port
I knew when it was going to be departing
its next destination now this
information could be either good or bad
for you because you could be like me and
way too invested as soon as I knew that
boat was coming in I was checking the
vessel finder all the time I was
tracking it as it was moving through the
ocean and I was waiting for it to hit
the port once it hit the Fremantle Port
I jumped on the Harbor cams I was
watching that vehicle come in and unload
and then I was still tracking as those
Teslas were being trucked out to the
delivery Center so for me it was bad
because I was so emotionally invested
into this situation that I thought the
delivery was coming very soon
unfortunately what happened like most
people say is my estimated delivery date
actually changed as all of these
vehicles were shipped off the port
because our delivery Center has a very
small maximum capacity it meant they
were delivering them in batches and
unfortunately my car was somewhere at
the end of the batch so my delivery date
got pushed from the start of November to
the end of November even though the
vehicle was pushed back I knew that it
was now in the country and it classified
as a registered vehicle in Australia
you're able to jump onto a website
called the register of approved vehicle
search or ravs for short you can type in
your VIN number and it will
automatically tell you that this vehicle
has or hasn't been registered in
Australia usually once they come off the
port and they've been cleared through
customs then they also get entered into
rabs this rabs is one of the most final
crucial steps because that means your
estimated delivery date is coming very
very soon for me personally once those
delivery dates started jumping around it
only took one business day before I got
another text message from Tesla saying
your Tesla Model Y is now ready for
scheduled delivery the schedule delivery
text message was great all you had to do
was literally jump on your phone press
the link sent to you in the text message
and then pick a day that was convenient
for you unfortunately for us here in
Western Australia the delivery Center is
only open throughout the week and the
delivery time slots weren't very good
for instance we picked it up on a Friday
at 9 30 in the morning that was the only
time slot available that week you cannot
pick it up over the weekend you can only
pick it up at these specified times so
if your workplace or your lifestyle
isn't flexible you might actually have
to think around how you can go and pick
up this vehicle like I mentioned
previously there was a mad rush to get
our paperwork and documentation sorted
the day before delivery actually
occurred however the day before delivery
for us and in our situation we go to
Tesla express delivery confirmation now
I would believe believe that you would
get this text message significantly
sooner if they'd sorted out your
paperwork when they were supposed to but
for us it literally was the day before
nonetheless this was a good text message
to receive because it means your vehicle
is ready for delivery it's scheduled and
waiting for you now delivery Day Has
Come and it is one of the most exciting
days it is unlike any other luxury car
experience now when you usually buy a
luxury car you walk into the dealership
there's all sorts of shows there's some
champagne there's probably flowers and
they peel off the magical rug over the
car with Tesla however you walk into an
old Warehouse you approach a bench full
of Tesla staff you show them your app
and you show them your driver's license
you have to accept delivery before you
even see the car they walk you to your
vehicle and walk away so they are truly
expecting you to know everything about
this vehicle before you even take
delivery they want you to know how to
use the app they want you know how to
use the screen they're not really too
keen on showing you unless they
genuinely have to so make sure you do
your research and keep looking at all
these Tesla videos they are incredible
be helpful and there are some great
content creators on YouTube to be able
to explain all of this our vehicle in
Australia obviously came from the
Shanghai Factory and it was 99.99
perfect there was genuinely no Faults
that we could see with it on the day
there was no panel gaps there was no
scratches it was Immaculate there was a
little bit of dust here and there but
that's not really something you can be
too upset about and we didn't really
have to go through that full checklist
because once you go through that
checklist I feel like it removes the
enjoyment and excitement about your
delivery experience you have to go
through meticulously tick off all these
items and figure out if anything is
wrong with your brand new purchase
thankfully the production is getting
significantly better and the Shanghai
Factory is producing vehicles that are
nearly Flawless like I said 99.99 there
still was a 0.1 error in our vehicle
unfortunately the seat belts for some
reason on the rear white seats left
small little scuff marks we can't get
them out with email Tesla so we'll see
what happens with that situation but
unfortunately I think there's some sort
of Grease or oil on those seat belts and
as they rest and sit on those white
seats they eventually leave marks be
prepared that your model y will most
likely not come with 100 fully charged
ours came with a 93 charged which was
still really really good once we charged
it to 100 it indicated to us that we
could drive 435 kilometers on a single
charge now we live about 500 kilometers
away from this delivery Center so we put
that to the test literally on the first
day unfortunately you're nowhere near
that 400 kilometer range driving at 110
kilometers an hour basically in pristine
perfect conditions it only managed to
hit about 300 kilometers before it was
indicating it needs to stop at a
Supercharger so luckily for us there is
one supercharger between us and that
manages to make the distance quite
easily it supercharges super quick in
about 20 minutes we went from 30 to 100
to make it back to our destination so
overall it was a good experience but
that is definitely one of the most
disappointing elements of the entire
order process is the fact that the range
is not as good as promised now I
understand that this was going to occur
but I just genuinely didn't think it was
going to be that much of a difference
compared to its estimator range to its
actual range anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching I hope this video gave you
clarity about your Tesla Model y
experience and what you can Expect When
You're Expecting I'm not sure if I'm
going to keep creating these Tesla
videos so feel free to leave a comment
down below if you want to see more of
these content potentially in some shorts
long form I'm not entirely sure but let
me know either way if you enjoyed the
content nonetheless feel free to hit
that subscribe button and like always
you will see me here next Monday